this cookie that kind of brings me back
to my roots in my childhood hi i'm
nathan and today i'm going to show you
how to make pineapple tart pineapple
tart is a buttery cookie that has
pineapple jam on top of it one important
thing my aunt told me to recognize is
when you get the canned pineapple for
the pineapple tart is to make sure it's
stored in its juices not like the sugary
syrup type
so when you're cooking the pineapple jam
it's very very important to get all the
moisture out so cook it until it's very
dry and when you think it's done go
ahead and take it out and put it in a
strainer and let it sit there for about
20 minutes or so just so all the
moisture really gets out of there
one nice subtlety about this pineapple
jam is that it's usually flavored with a
spice my aunt likes to use cinnamon but
typically you can find anise and cloves
as well typically this is made for lunar
new year and what friends and family
would do is they make it homemade and
they would give it to their friends and
family because the pineapple in chinese
culture symbolizes wealth so when you
give it to someone that you care for
it's like you're wishing prosperity and
wealth to them
it's very difficult to find pineapple
tarts here in the states so every time i
when i go back to singapore i always
have like my friends who are also
singaporean asked me to bring it back
because this is a very special cookie to
all of us and it's something that we all
like to share together
for those of you who might have seen
this video nikki reid and i made a video
about nikki trying to recreate this
cookie from her childhood which is
pineapple tart so i asked my aunt for
her recipe because this is something
that's also special to me to in my
childhood i was a bit concerned that she
wouldn't want me to share this family
recipe with the world but i was happy
when she told me that good food is meant
to be shared so this one is for you guys
my dad is from singapore but i was born
in america and i moved to asia at a very
early age because of my dad's work but
when i was just a little older i moved
back to states when i was five
growing up as an american asian i really
felt out of touch with my singaporean
heritage and that's why this cooking in
this recipe is very important to me
because it's this cookie that kind of
brings me back to my roots in my
childhood no matter what age i am
whenever i would go visit my aunt
hearing her voice just instantly makes
me feel like a child again and it's that
feeling that it's usually followed with
a nice homemade pineapple tart
so pineapple tart comes in a variety of
shapes today we're making one that kind
of looks like a sunflower and with a
lattice on top the ones i had growing up
that my aunt made were was like a ball
stuffed with it inside choose your own
adventure one important thing about the
pineapple tart is to make sure to let it
rest after it bakes
i know you'll be tempted to eat it
because it's gonna be warm and gooey but
trust me it's gonna taste a lot better
if you let it rest the flavor is gonna
just come together a lot more and it's
gonna intensify so when you bite into a
pineapple tart the first thing that hits
you is that crumbly buttery cookie
and it's nicely followed with the
pineapple jam which is like sweet it's
tart but it's not as tart as like a
regular pineapple it's a lot more mellow
and a lot sweeter and it's just the
combination of it all just kind of works
really well it's hard to say like what
singaporean food is because it's made up
of so many different cultural identities
so no matter where i go i've seen to be
always drawn to all sorts of asian foods
but the one thing that really ties me to
my childhood is pineapple tart
oh yes
you